hey guys Rob here and i'm joined by mike
that ram hello he's been to see Tyson
full too right yeah we're both planet
yeah you actually had gotten into events
as well yeah Vince Zampella dhruba
mcboyd were there to talk to me
afterwards about what we played what
titanfall 2 is doing that titanfall one
didn't and kind of just a slew of
details that kind of just collided with
us so you played a couple of games
overall what do you think it's really
it's just as fluid which is a he
overused term now but like we time a
tight ball you can say it's still fluid
there are a bunch of new abilities that
you could see upsetting the balance but
from the two matches I played they very
well play into that whole overarching
kind of like get into your Mac grapple
hook someone else kick him jump down
switch your heavy weapon it's still it
still feels very much like this great
moment to moment gameplay that titanfall
had me and you were talking about is
there enough that's different to really
warrant us yeah yeah that's my concern
because I played one game of it and I
thought it was amazing like it was
really excited playing it but I then
come back to war in here III I thought
you know what the first game was
exciting for the exact same reasons and
i'm wondering if it has done enough to
be different from the first game what do
you think so i think the main thing that
they're doing there's six titans now
none of them are the ones we played in
the first game they're all like they're
more super powers right they're all kind
of designed around these certain themes
like I on the one that I played is like
all laser abilities you can throw down
these laser trip mines that destroy
pilots real easily you have a
shoulder-mounted really like quick burst
laser cannon like one person grapple
hook tied hit him right out the sky one
of my better moments but then you know
you have his like his ultimate ability
which is like you just it's charged
chest laser that just destroys other
Titans or do this so that's where is it
Vince Zampella was saying that it's
gonna become almost like a street
fighter thing they said like a fighting
games were a big influence you know like
you see it's got a visual vocabulary
you'll see an eye on come around the
corner see his chest laser charging and
you're like I'm not gonna block that get
back around the corner get ready to use
my you know throw my mind's down it's
really a preemptive kind of combat
almost like a game of cat and mouse yeah
like I guess the chest like a light
chess games kind of like thinking maybe
like a step ahead you know you can kind
of see flames come around the corner
like oh they're using scores to tighten
my shields not gonna really work well
against and I should back off hopefully
my buddy comes in there's a very there's
a lot more or forethought involved
here right and from the trailer we also
saw a bit of Titan come food yeah did
you engage in any comfort no
unfortunately the Titans we got to use
didn't have the malleability like the
roads this election yeah I know that
when I couldn't do it either okay and
overall i mean i think the foot type of
one great game a lot of fanfare on it's
released but then after a few months or
the community sort of fell off a cliff
yeah a little bit so they're trying to
like implement this longevity right with
an RPG progression system the person
doing it with time fall to is one who
introduced that nine years ago with call
of duty 4 modern warfare OBC first like
a prestige system kind of you know this
RPG progression within the shooter
structure they didn't tell me too many
details about that but you know you're
hoping like the ps4 players now it's not
just xbox one or gonna like help
maintain that multiplayer base past just
a few weeks right yeah Mike fantastic
work thank you so much and for more on
tight simple to stay tuned to gamespot
you